et j'accueille à présent sur le plateau
du 78 en ce lundi Nicolas S bonsoir vous
êtes artiste résident à la Commanderie
des Templiers à aencour votre atrelier
qui se trouve sur cette commune dans la
zone d'activité des des quatre arbres
vous êtes artist sculpteur également
vous réalisez des œuvres monumentales
dans votre atelier la prochaine sera
dévoilée à quelques privilégiés ce sera
dès demain quelques privilégiés sur
saquentin et sur la région franilienne
et ensuite cette œuvre va partir pour
valencienne ce sera le 21 mai 22 mai
installation on va rapidement voir les
images de cette œuvre que vous avez
réalisé justement sur cette cette
agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline elle s'appelle hv11 vous pouvez
nous la présenter et puis peut-être nous
expliquer son nom également c'est une
œuvre monumentale en acier trois lines
d'acier à peu près de 4 tonnes
euh H11 simplement parce que H c'est
l'initial du matériau h V c'est c'est
initial de la ville de Valencienne et 11
c'est l'année on s'est rencontré pour ce
projet comment est est né justement ce
ce projet 2011 vous l'avez dit c'est une
commande de la ville de Valencienne
c'est une commande de la ville de
Valencienne c'est suite à un festival de
sculpture que j'ai réalisé dans le Nord
qui s'appelait Esco Riv des rives qui
partait de Valencienne qui est regroupé
une vingtaine de villes sur le bord de
de de l'Esco du F d'esco et à cette
occasion j'ai rencontré donc la ville de
Valencienne son maère adjoint à la
Culture Monsieur Patrick rousiè euh et
c'est comme ça que le projet est parti
par par un intérêt du travail et au fur
à mesure une une rencontre une rencontre
avec avec la ville avec des espaces et
c'est comme ça que que le projet est né
rencontre avec l'espace ça c'est
important parce que chacune de vos
œuvres se construit en fonction de
l'espace également où où elle se trouve
lors lorsqu'on travaille dans pour la
commande publique il faut tenir compte
du lieu dans lequel la sculpture va se
situer parce queon va on va tenir compte
des fluxs des point de vue de l'espace
pour dimensionner l'œuvre à sa à sa
juste juste à sa juste échelle pour pas
être trop présente mais pour qu'elle
soit présente aussi pour qu'elle puisse
exister d'un manière juste là vous va
travailler dans vos ateliers l'acier
c'est quelque chose d'assez imposant
quelque chose de lourd l'enjeu pour vous
c'est d'en faire quelque chose de léger
toujours exactement c'est c'est toujours
dans une sculpture la prise de risque le
danger la remise en question c'est ça
qui me fait avancer et dans cette pièce
particulièrement c'est une une œuvre qui
a été très technique c'est pas la plus
grosse mais c'est la plus technique
parce que chaque il y a des énormes
porte à fou dans la construction de la
pièce ce qui fait tout l'intérêt de la
sculpture et comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est presque 3 tonnes et demi 4
tonnes de d'acier en en suspension qui
tiennent qui reposent finalement sur
trois pointes sur trois angles et cette
idée de d' jouer la matière de la rendre
légère alors que elle est lourde c'est
un peu remettre en cause les choses même
ça veut dire que quand vous avez
travaillé constamment vous avez modifié
adapté des choses aussi par rapport au
vous voulez ou tout était déjà prévu TR
cadrié sur plan sur des choses sur des
projets comme ça il faut vraiment
vraiment savoir où ce qu'on va parce que
techniquement c'est compliqué ensuite il
y a un site donc on anal le site on fait
une première étude on voit si ça
fonctionne par rapport au site et après
on on on part dans la la grande pièce
mais si on fait pas un travail d'étudees
au préalable on peut pas calculer l'ASS
qu' nous faut le coût le temps le budget
de l're alors comment vous avez
travaillé vous avez fait des des croquis
au départ des schémas comment vous
travaillez dans vos ateliers avant de
vous lancer sur la réalisation comme là
là par exemple quand je sur une pièce
comme ça c'est une analyse du site qui
est une place à Valencienne qui fait à
la fois office de de de rondpoint une
grande place que le public peut
traverser donc voilà ensuite on commencé
à faire une j'ai laissé ses plans et ses
photos c'est longtemps sur mon sur mon
bureau de manière à à à se appréhender
le site et comme j'ai un travail qui est
pas un travail euh qui est toujours un
travail d'atelier donc du coup moi
j'aime bien avoir cette liberté à la
fois il a des avantages et la fois des
inconvénients parce que pour faire des
projets comme ça justement il fautussi
prendre très longtemps en avance pour
être juste au moment lorsqu'on veut
rentre en premier projet ça a pris 6
mois et en gros lesé laaboration du
projet de manière à ce que euh dans le
travail dans le travail dans le cours et
de la pensée du travail d'atelier bien
on puisse je puisse répondre en même
temps à l'espace public et c'est ça qui
qui est qui qui est délicat et après il
y a la mise en œuvre qui est aussi
important et donc la capacité aussi de
pouvoir réaliser ce projet seul comme
j'ai fait jusqu comme je fait jusqu'à
présent l'œuvre a été conçue ici à 50 an
neline à en cour elle va partir le 21
mai et l'installation ce sera le 22
comment vous allez la transporter ben du
coup convoie exceptionnel convoie
exceptionnel catégorie 2 pour être très
technique elle sera pas démontée elle
est déjà tel sera démontée parce que
telqu c'est catégorie 3 et là c'est
beaucoup plus cher donc il y a quand
même une un rapport économique il faut
tenir compte non non catégorie 2 ça
c'est suffisant donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut la démonter ça veut dire qu'il y
aura une partie après c'est très timé
parce qu'il y a les Gru qui sont après
le mardi à 14h précise pour rassembler
tous les tous les éléments la sculpture
sera en trois parties de manière à ce
qu'elle puisse sortir de l'atelier et
qu'on puisse la remonter récemment il y
a un critique d'art Jean-Louis Poidevin
je vais le citer qui écrivait que la
plus c'était la plus radicale et la plus
complexe de vos de vos sculptures est-ce
que c'est le cas vous êtes d'accord avec
ça ah oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
que euh jusqu'à présent j'ai fait une
très grosse pièce pour la ville de de
Montelimar HM h aussi réalisé sur je
fait ici mais c'est une Prelle c'est une
une sculpture en fait de poutrelle
ouverte donc techniquement
elle était plus légère même sielle était
plus plus importante celle-ci étant un
une ligne carrée fermé donc on a j'ai
augmenté le poids de chaque ligne mais
aussi l'acier comme vous le savez se
déforme don et comme il y a un seul
point d'accroche qui quasiment qui se
joue sur 20 20 cm² euh on peut
facilement imaginer qu'il y a des
déformations et donc c'est pour ça il a
fallu extrêmement architecturer à
l'intérieur mettre des renforts partout
de manière à ce que la sculpture tienne
et qu'elle tienne aussi s'il y a du
public qui monte dessus pour fêter une
victoire éventuelle de viille de
Valencienne je sais pas pour l'instant
c'est la victoire du paris-germain on va
laisser le temps à Valencienne de
récupérer le titre on va laisser le
temps aux Parisiens de le célébrer on va
parler tout de même aussi de votre
parcours vous êtes né en 65 à Rodez vous
avez fait des études à l'école des B de
perpignon et à quel moment vous vous
êtes dit je vais travailler l'acier
parce que c'était pas le cas au tout
début vous travaillez pas sur l'acier
non je faisais la peinture il y a 20 ans
je plus de 20 ans je faisais la peinture
mais c'est le travail qui amène
les qui vient qui vient qui vient à vous
euh c'est le travail de de l'artiste
c'est de pouvoir aussi c'est de faire de
de de produire des images ou des volumes
mais aussi de quoi et puis de lire dans
son travail ce qu'on produit et
lorsqu'on produit on met en place des
systèmes qui peuvent devenir après
théoriques ou
bien voilà théorique mais mais il faut
trouver aussi la raisonance en soi c'est
ça qui est difficile c'est pour pouvoir
avancer et développer le travail il faut
être sur les deux fronts en même temps
mais de travailler ce matériau de
travailler l'acier ça vous procure
quelle sensation quel sentiment en tant
qu'artiste aussi je travaille ce
matériaux parce qu'il est il est
maniable et on peut on peut le souder le
couper l'allonger on peut faire ce qu'on
veut il répond à il répond exactement
sur qui répond exactement au développer
formé que je que je développe qui sont
des lignes euh et si je travaille la
Prelle comme ça c'est que je peux aussi
gérer euh toute la réalisation du comme
je disais à l'instant du de de l'idée
générale de la sculpture jusqu'à sa
finalité donc il y a aussi là qui est
très important vous avez des souvenirs
encore des premières réalisations que
vous avez pu faire en acier
euh oui est-ce que ça a beaucoup évolué
justement est-ce que vous êtes satisfait
aujourd'hui avec le recul des premières
réalisations que vous avez pu faire euh
assez oui vous dites assez c'estàd que
vous avez quelques regrets des choses
que vous nez peuttre à l'ép desè vous
savez on fait des pièces qui sont
paromment réussies mais qui sont pas
super voilà après il y a des pièces qui
font qui font œuvre dans le temps des
pièces auquelles on revient on sait que
ces piècesl sont importantes parce qu'il
y a eu des enjeux al so qu' ont été
faites parce qu'on a souffert pour les
faire ou soit qu'elles sont venu très
facilement par accident parce que des
fois ça arrive il y a pas de recette il
y a pas de recette il y a pas de miracle
il faut travaille tous les jours il y a
une évolution sur sur votre façon de
travailler en tout cas ah oui une
évolution même depuis depuis que j'ai un
nouvel atelier qui est beaucoup plus
grand don du coup je peux travailler sur
des plus grands formats et c'est très
important parce que ça me permet aussi
de placer mon travail sur au niveau de
du milieu artistique voilà je commence à
avoir des des très grosses pièces et
c'est pour et c'est pour moi très
important parce que ça permet de d'poser
dans des villes faire des gros projets
avoir un autre regard du milieu
professionnel voilà votre atelier vous
le disz he plus grand aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui bien installé dans le
département à Saint-Quentin àencour vous
y êtes bien sur cette commune d'éencour
suis que vous êtes pas natif du secteur
donc vous enz pas de partir vous allez
pas du tout je suis très bien ici je
compte bien rester très longtemps
d'ailleurs je me plais sur ce territoire
5 anine je me PLA sur la commun encs
parce que j'y travaille voilà je suis un
artiste heureux vous réfléchissez déjà
sur les prochaines œuvres Ben est déjà
en cours vous pouvez nous en dire plus
c'est un secret non ce sont c'est là
c'est dans l'atelier il y a trois lignes
sur un petit socle qui sont scotchés ça
ve pour l'inston euh ça parle qu'à moi
c'est scotché depuis euh depuis 15 jours
3 semaines h parce qu'il faut attendre
que que l'idée de la sculture soit soit
vraiment là à lié parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est encore plus plus
c'est une une remise en jeu de ce que
j'ai fait l'assemblage est plus osé
encore donc voilà donc c'est on va
prendre encore des risques c'est faut
faire attention parce que c'est quand
même dangereux h mais euh ça fait partie
du métier du sculpteur dangereux oui
dangereux parce que quand vous avez
plusieurs tonnes sur la tête euh
suspendu ou quand on dépasse des lignes
il y a des fois le PE peut vous prendre
donc c'est quand même un travail où il
faut être très concentré et même si
c'est on pense que c'est un travail très
physique c'est pas que physique la
scuure la strulure monumentale en tout
cas pour moi moi je je la je la vis
comme ça comme étant quelque chose de
très mental parce qu'il faut projeter
déjà l'œuvre dans un site par exemple
mais aussi lorsqu'on travaille il faut
être il faut imaginer le mouvement il
faut faut avoir une très bonne
méthodologie de travail pour pouvoir
bien
une ligne dans un sens pour pouvoir
après monter l'ensemble de manière à
travailler en toute sécurité et et et
pouvoir monter sa pièce simplement quoi
et votre nouvelle réalisation
H11 qui sera donc présenté à quelques
privilégiés demain on a pu en apercevoir
quelques images il y a quelques instants
puisqu'on vous a suivi au cours de la
réalisation Patrick Jacques de dixmut
qui vous a suivi qui qui a signé ces ces
images que vous avez vu ce soir et la
présentation ensuite à Valencienne dès
le 22 pour l'installation inauguration
tout début juin 6 juin 6 Ju merci
Nicolas d'être venu sur ce pl